there are seven ways that you can buy
property
below market value bmv
properties and in this video i'm going
to be revealing the secrets
and sharing with you the top seven ways
to finding and securing properties
below market value added discount
bargain properties if you like the sound
of that
stay around the best one is probably the
last one so stick around till the end
also do me a massive favor and smash the
like button
and also if you're not subscribed i do
videos every single day like this
so if you want to succeed in property
then subscribe to the channel and turn
the notification bell on
so number one of the seven ways is
through estate agents now this is really
really straightforward but
there are hundreds of thousands of
properties
on the market with estate agents now
sometimes people think
yeah but estate agents they don't have
the best deals
but do you think really that if you want
to sell your house
and you're really motivated you might
you might
call an estate agent and tell them that
you need to sell your house fast
of course so if you are connected with
estate agents
if you've got good relationships with
estate agents they are
bound to pass you some really juicy
below marketable deals
i've received many many of my deals to
estate agents so that is number one
number two is via deal
sources deal packages there are people
whose
job it is to find properties below
market value
and do all the hard work the
negotiations on your behalf
and you'll pay them a fixed finder's fee
for these properties now if you are
going to buy through a deal saucer
do you always do your due diligence not
only on the
deal itself but also on the deal saucer
so i would highly recommend my business
partner alistair cunningham from
bettersource if you wanted to buy a deal
check out better source limited i'll
leave a link in the description number
three
is direct to vendor ads so there are
certain online platforms
like gumtree craigslist
facebook marketplace where motivated
sellers
advertise their properties on these
sites actually you can go to gumtree
right now
gumtree.com type properties for sale in
your particular area and there are
people selling their houses on gumtree
now
you can't kind of have to be pretty
motivated to put your house
on gumtree so you're dealing with people
that are motivated to sell their house
sometimes the people put their house on
gumtree they might not be motivated
it might be a really bad house but it's
a great opportunity to scroll through
what a little tip that i do as well
is i'll search from oldest listed
so i'll be looking through all the
properties on gumtree in my area that
have been on a little while
and then i'll ring them up and i'll say
hey your house has been on the market
now for
over a month on gumtree what's the
problem why do you think it's not
selling and i'll just create a little
bit of pain
and then offer them a heavily below
market value offer so that's number
three
number four is social media
social media is filled with property
investors
property sellers there are communities
there are groups
so you should be tapping into that and
trying to find deals
also put yourself out there put on your
linkedin that you are a property
investor because when you tell the world
that you're a property investor
and what happens is suddenly deals start
coming to you so
utilize social media number five
is auctions auctions are a great way to
find bargain properties
now sometimes if you just turn up to the
auction on the day
and you've not done any due diligence
and you start bidding you could lose
money and you can
really really waste a lot of time as
well so my suggestion would be
if you're going to go to an auction make
sure that you have a
maximum bidding price do your due
diligence before you go
but people that sell their houses on
auction genuinely generally
have properties that they need to sell
fast and they will often take
a hit on the actual market value another
tip you can do in auctions
is you can offer a pre-auction offer so
you can ring up the auctioneer and you
can say hey
this property is going to auction
however i'd like to make my offer
beforehand
and you can put a below market value off
that and you just don't know
they might say yes number six is
traditional advertising so traditional
advertising what do i mean by that
i mean things like flyers little little
leaflets through people's doors
that say i'm looking to buy your house
quickly
if you'd be open to a quick sale message
me on such and such a number
you can put these flyers not just
through people's doors but you can also
put them in newspapers
you can create editorials and put them
in newspapers which doesn't actually
cost any money
you can put them up on the shop windows
sometimes as well for
free little wanted signs in places like
sainsbury's
so traditional paper advertising can be
a really powerful way
and then finally my favorite way
is drive buys what do i mean by
drive-bys so
everywhere i'm driving if i'm in
birmingham my hometown
my home area or if i'm around
beckonsfield where i live now
or if i'm driving around liverpool when
i'm driving around i'm always
looking for opportunities and even if i
can't buy the house myself because i
haven't got the money or it's not in my
patch i can always package it and sell
it onto somebody else
because the people that have the most
deals are usually the winners so when
i'm driving i'm looking for little
opportunities i'm looking for derelict
houses that might look like they've been
abandoned and then i'm gonna go into
land
registry pay three pounds find out the
owner and send them a
letter i'm looking for houses that are
up for sale that have got
two or three for sale boards with
different agents that means they're
probably pretty motivated
and then i'm gonna get in touch and
offer them a little
cheeky offer so those are the top seven
ways that i found in finding below
market value offers
i hope you enjoyed that if there's any
other ways that you've personally
experienced or you're considering
finding a below market value offer on a
property i'd love to hear about them
comment them below and maybe i'll
include them in my next video
thanks for watching please do smash the
subscribe button
and turn on the notifications smash the
like button as well and if you want to
learn a bit more about how to speak to
sellers
and how to put forward your offer i'd
highly recommend this video up here
where i teach you how to close
how to put forward your offer thanks for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]